well new video today of the chaos at the
border border agents literally cutting
the razor wild to let illegal immigrants
in and just miles away from where
Homeland Security secretary Alejandro
mayorkas met with the president of
Honduras today near the border is an
illegal immigrant Town that's right I
said an illegal immigrant town a
developer is reportedly selling border
crossers home plots without asking them
for any documentation and all of this is
happening as the Border crisis hits
another record more than 230 thousand
apprehensions in August the most ever
for any August and while it appears the
Biden Administration is doing nothing
about it at least Mexico is law
enforcement is blocking thousands of
migrants from riding up to the U.S
border on a freight train called The
Beast
okay so an illegal immigrant town uh
David you know I thought part of the
American dream was to be able to
purchase a home the young American
Family purchase the home save up for
years I mean I I know people who are
still saving to buy that first home this
seems like a little bit of a giveaway uh
what do you think well it's not just a
giveaway there's a little more to this
by the way what they're really building
whether it's here at Colony Ridge which
is the development or what Brandon
Johnson wants to do in Chicago let's
call them what they are they're illegal
alien gulags because they're sending
illegal aliens over to be in segmented
areas I looked into this developer's
background and this is someone who's
filed a number of lawsuits even if he's
not harmed William Trey Harris is his
name and he's the Army Corps of
Engineers out of Galveston has looked
into him questions about the properties
he owns the quality of the property fix
inroads this is another grifter off the
system some finding a way to sell
something and I got to tell you when you
when you dig into the backgrounds of
these stories you really should look at
the people who are doing this they're
either getting paid by the
administration like these ngos Endeavor
and these other groups that have these
massive contracts the hotel years who
just fill their hotels like the row
hotel where this guy in Colony Ridge dig
a little bit deeper I found lawsuits
going back that he'd filed 2021 2019 and
more so it's an illegal alien Gulag send
them there where's the police where's
the fire where's the emergency plan
who's you know think about all the
things that have to be in place permit
in zoning all the things that you need
to actually develop property yeah and
even the media is admitting there's a
huge problem at the border today take a
look at this headline from The New York
Times They are saying the permanent
migrant crisis look at that and then
they have a quote and it says the
fundamental problem facing the Biden
Administration on the southern border
where every attempt to get ahead of the
extraordinary numbers trying to cross or
claim Asylum has been overwhelmed so
even they are starting to acknowledge
this and I want to also take a listen to
something that President Biden said
recently about the Border crisis let's
take a listen to this
we need our colleagues to act for
decades immigration reform has been a
bipartisan in this country unfortunately
the mega Republican Congressman of my
predecessor spent four years gutting the
immigration system under my predecessor
they continued undermine our border
security today blocking bipartisan
reform
okay so he is blaming this problem at
the border on Republicans and the the
previous president but I want to take a
look at this graphic right here showing
some interesting information take a look
at this the yellow line and you see at
the bottom that's 2020 under President
Trump red blue green lines those are the
years under Biden so it it kind of uh
brings some questions about what the
President says Lisa what do you think
about that well he's a liar right I mean
he he started this crisis intentionally
and he's continuing to drive it and the
media is still not being honest about
what's actually happening here in fact
they try to shut down the truth you
can't call it an invasion despite the
fact that we're seeing over 9 000
illegal Crossings per day you can't say
they're trying to import cheap labor
when Joe Biden's trying to make hundreds
of thousands of migrants eligible to
work in the United States you can't say
they're trying to replace American
voters when Joe Biden allegedly is
trying to give out IDs and you look at
States now moving towards like
Pennsylvania the automatic voter
registration when we've seen in other
states like California where legal
immigrants have been registered to vote
through that so you know they tell you
you can't say all these things yet if
you actually dig in and look what's
happening that sure seems like what's
taking place and also I will remind you
it was Obama in 2006 who warned us about
an influx of illegal immigrants in the
country that it was going to depress
Blue Collar wages and it was going to
overburden her safety net yet you know
obviously Democrats are singing a
different tune now just Biden's blaming
everybody else manga Republicans or is
it Mega I never know what he's really
saying
19 1973.
I mean really he's part of the problem
he's a liar but he's been there longer
than some of the Republicans he's
blaming I think he was born there Tom
let me ask you does it say something to
you that even now the New York Times is
commenting on this saying Biden has a
problem at the border the New York Times
yeah well it's rust out thought over
there he's the one of the conservatives
there and I do like him he's a little
soft sometimes and he's soft on this one
he says it's a choice the choice is to
go further into punitive and callous
territory that the Trump Administration
engaged in so he's saying oh Trump was
obviously way too harsh and the the you
know the choices between the harshness
of trump and obviously the
ineffectiveness of Biden but that's not
the truth I mean Trump wasn't hard
enough most conservatives know I mean
Trump talked a good game about the wall
and everything else and he did he had
some good policies to remain in Mexico
policy but he wasn't able to get a
handle on it we still had borders that
were essentially open during that time
and he was first frustrated the whole
time but he never was able to get a
handle on it they were able to demonize
him with this family separation thing
which Obama also engaged in it was all
fake so he got a little overwhelmed by
that and so the idea that he was too
harsh no but I think even this
Administration or I mean Biden doesn't I
don't even think he knows what he's
doing but the people who are behind this
they like it they like the flood of
immigration and they think we'll just
work this all out later eventually we're
going to be able to get citizenship he's
talking about oh we've got a uh you know
we've got to get comprehensive reform we
don't want comprehensive reform we know
what that means it means amnesty and it
and then what you do is what happened in
the 1980s gave amnesty to all these
illegal aliens and then we said okay we
started fresh now we're going to secure
the Border they didn't do it yeah it
just happens all over again well it's
just a magnet it just invites more and
more illegal immigration we do that I
mean honestly we need to shut down the
border and shut down immigration until
we get a handle on this to be perfectly
honest I mean it really is you could
create entire new States based off of
the amount of people that have come here
this city alone that they're creating
this illegal immigrant town is the size
of Washington D.C under by Joe Biden by
the way over a hundred thousand hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else